PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Do you find it
challenging to
maintain identities
across different environments
and hybrid and multi-cloud
deployments?
Do you wish you can leverage
your existing identity
investments for Anthos?
Well, keep watching
as we cover how
you can use Anthos to simplify
identity management for users
and workloads.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
I'm Priyanka Vergadia, and
welcome to "Anthos 101."
With Anthos, our goal
is to make it seamless
for you to modernize and
manage your workloads
in an environment
that you prefer,
whether it is on-prem,
Google Cloud, Edge,
or a different cloud.
Anthos spans across
multiple environments,
and each is built on different
identity store, for example,
Active Directory for on-prem,
Cloud Identity for Google
Cloud, and AWS IAM for AWS.
In addition to
employee identity,
you may need to manage partner,
[INAUDIBLE] identity, workload
identity, or customer
identity, further increasing
the complexity.
Traditionally, Google
Cloud has offered
a synchronization-based
identity model,
requiring you to synchronize
identities with Google Cloud.
While this may work
for certain scenarios,
you may have concerns around
consistency and latency
for a hybrid or
multi-cloud deployment.
With Anthos, we want to
meet you where you are.
Anthos Identity Service
extends existing capabilities
and it enables you to use
third-party identity providers
and authentication protocols,
following a federation model.
This service can be deployed
quickly in your Anthos GKE
cluster, enabling protocols
such as OpenID Connect.
You no longer need to
synchronize identities
to Google Cloud or
worry about consistency
across environments.
It saves time and
reduces friction
during the onboarding process.
Anthos on-prem
offers OIDC support,
which enables
authentication via G Cloud
or through Cloud Console.
Let's walk through how
that experience looks like.
Say you are a platform
administrator managing
a small team of
developers, and you're
interested in providing access
to the Kubernetes API server
to debug issues or perform
cluster management tasks
using Kubectl.
After creating a user
cluster for GKE on-prem,
you can run a gkectl command to
generate a login configuration
file.
You will need to populate
this file with values
specific to your
identity provider,
such as issuer URL,
redirect URL, and client ID.
You can enable one or multiple
identity providers to support
needs of different user groups.
The file can be securely
distributed to developers
using an accessible URL.
In order to restrict access
based on privileges granted
to authenticated
users, you can use
Kubernetes role-based
access control
to create cluster roles that
grant specific privileges
to users and groups.
As a developer, you can
install the G Cloud SDK
without requiring a Google
Cloud Identity account
and install the Anthos
autho components
to enable third-party
OIDC authentication.
Simply run gcloud
anthos auth login,
to view the list of
available clusters
and specify a cluster
flag to log in.
Based on your Kubernetes
RBAC privileges,
you can now run Kubectl
commands to complete
your required tasks.
Moving forward, we are planning
to enable additional protocols,
such as LDAP, to support
authentication needs
for multiple environments,
including Google Cloud,
on-prem, and other clouds.
We're also extending our OIDC
capabilities to other clouds
to create a consistent
multi-cloud experience.
Anthos Identity Service is
designed to work seamlessly
with other Anthos components
and your existing identity
investments.
Beyond user authentication,
you can also
enable workload
authentication for workloads
running in GKE to
consume services
provided by Google APIs.
Simply configure a
Kubernetes service account
to automatically
authenticate when
accessing Google Cloud APIs.
There's no need to
worry about safeguarding
private keys for PKI and client
certificates or managing bearer
and bootstrap tokens.
Anthos Identity Service
provides a fully integrated,
enterprise-ready solution
for authentication that
is built with security in mind.
As you can see, Anthos
Identity Service
offers a seamless solution
for managing authentication
to multiple Anthos
GKE environments,
allowing you to leverage
existing identity investments
and streamline the
onboarding process.
To learn more about
Anthos Identity
Service and our identity
features, check out
the documentation below.
And for more Anthos
content, don't
forget to subscribe and follow
the "Anthos 101" playlist.
[MUSIC PLAYING]